so my first mission for you is to pick
one word to describe your experience and
tell me why you chose
it
oh no pressure
I'm is my word
unsurpassed unsurpassed okay nothing
that I've ever done by way of an
activity or a television
show has been more
stimulating so I it which is not to say
I was great at it I did I hope okay and
have a lot of fun it
was unsurpassed it outstripped my
expectations wonderful love hearing that
Kevin did you come up with anything yet
maybe uh might be a little bit too deep
but um go deep we love deep yeah watch
this I think it was very uh shattering
and kind
of it shattered my own reality actually
in my own life because I thought there
were so many life lessons in this um
that was true to people and from my own
experiences and I think you know even
Deontay could relate to this that you
know in Hollywood there's a lot of
traders in real life a lot of friends
who could even be Traders or will betray
you and um I found it very shattering of
my own real world and it related a lot
and um you know there were times of uh
faith that I thought were really great
that um you know off camera Deontay and
I were speaking about that really helped
me uh get through all of this and it
kind of related to my own life I was
like man sometimes a lot of times
actually you just need Faith you just
need a
reminder uh you don't always get the
luxury of having Deonte around though
for it but it's just uh it really really
reminded me of real life and I had to do
a lot of reflection afterwards wow
that's amazing though that's that's even
better than I think anybody could ask
for Deontay what about you um for me for
me it was it was one way I can describe
as a blessing for me you know um a lot
of people see me get emotion emotional
um on this show which they they
definitely didn't expect I mean I didn't
expect it as well um but you know I I I
don't shy away from um from showing my
emotion because I always tell other men
that you know it's okay to cry because
it's only a cleansing we can only bottle
bottle up and hold so much until our cup
run it over and you don't want to be the
person that your cup build up so your
your cup build up with water so much to
the point you don't have a place to
release and if you don't have a place to
release you're going to
self-destruct and sometime that
self-destruction can cause a lot of uh
things that you regret that you do or
you say so for me it was a blessing to
be able to release a lot of uh childhood
trauma uh in all of the places you know
I would I would have never expected but
you know as I look up on it I don't
regret anything that happened and um and
I embrace it all because it really
releases something out of me that I
really need I've been carrying for for
38 years so it's been a blessing that's
extraordinary that is so and I remember
you saying you really wanted to show men
that it's okay to feel their emotions
and and cry and you know talk about
their feelings as well so would you say
you definitely did that I think I I
think I I would I could say a mission
accomplished for sure because of the
background that I have been a been a ass
Whooper you know people would you know
they don't expect that they don't expect
that from me and um um and for me to be
able to display that you know amongst
the world I think it really going to
touch uh a lot of men around the world
that man if he able to be so vulnerable
on a show that's going to going to be um
broadcast around the world then why can
I in my everyday life or when things
come to my way because it's okay to
release and you know as we've been
taught up especially when you come up in
rural areas you always been taught to
don't show no love or don't don't show
no no sensitive side of you don't cry
because that show weakness but a lot of
things as human what we say and what we
do is very backwards in what you how you
really supposed to live a righteous life
and go or I would say Target life you
know a lot of the things is is is is
wrong I'll give you an example of one
say that everyone know you can't teach a
old dog new tricks that's a that's
that's I I that's that's that's a say
that uh uh that I don't agree with
because no matter how young or old that
we are if our brain is a sponge and if
we can't soak up information anymore
you're just living to die
what's living if you can't suck up any
information and learn so um you know um
I hope a lot of people take it away you
know this is not scripted this is real
emotions and um and um it was just a
blessing to be a part of it it really
was and to meet some me the guys and
some Kevin and and John you know I had
so much uh fun with those guys and to
see them again right now you know it
brings up old memories and that's why
you'll sometimes see me smiling and and
and uh I appreciate those guys of being
being a part of the of the show and um
and coming on as well and meeting them
wholeheartly I appreciate God beautiful
I feel like I just got a word that makes
me very
happy I want to thank y'all so much uh
we have such a short time and I wish I
could spend more time with y'all but got
to go I appreciate you so much for
sharing your those Deep Emotions and
that was wonderful thank you Shar thank
you very much for taking an interest